schwere rezession erwartet aber
deutschland steckt das weg und dem
nächsten jahr geht es wieder aufwärts
sagen die führenden deutschen
wirtschaftsinstitute reichen die
intensivbetten deutschlands mediziner
sehen das land auch bei einem anstieg
schwerer corona fälle gut gerüstet und
entscheidung bei den us-demokraten
bernie sanders gibt auf damit tritt
wollte biden bei der
präsidentschaftswahl gegen donald trump
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen ich freue mich dass sie dabei
sind
die welthandelsorganisation fürchtet
infolge der korona krise die tiefste
rezession die wir bisher erlebt haben
sie rechnet mit einem absturz des
globalen handels und bis zu 32 prozent
für deutschland sind die führenden
wirtschaftsinstitute sehr viel
optimistischer
in ihrem frühjahrsgutachten erwarten sie
in diesem jahr ein minus von 4,2 prozent
und sind zuversichtlich dass der
rückschlag relativ schnell wieder
aufgeholt werden kann
florian a üblicherweise setzen diese
ökonomen gemeinsam in der
bundespressekonferenz das unübliche aber
ist längst routine in zeiten von
stillgelegten autofabriken und
fluglinien die nicht mehr fliegen so
richtig die bekämpfung der korona
pandemie sei so sehr dürfte sie
deutschland in eine schwere rezession
stürzen sagen die führenden
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute heute wir
haben quasi die ökonomie in eine
schockstarre versetzt wir haben sie
eingefroren das bringt natürlich einen
massiven wirtschaftlichen einbruch mit
sich so erwarten die forscher für 2020
ein minus von 4,2 prozent
zum vergleich 2009 bei der finanzkrise
schrumpfte die deutsche wirtschaft um
fünf prozent ist das virus halbwegs im
griff könnte 2021 ein schnelles
widererstarken folgen plus 5,8 prozent
ich fühle mich jedenfalls ermutigt durch
diese diagnose dass ein rascher wieder
aufstieg möglich ist soweit und sobald
die voraussetzungen dafür gegeben sind
und es ist aufgabe der politik dazu
einen beitrag zu leisten man arbeite
daher bereits sagen wirtschafts und
finanzminister an ideen zu einem
weiteren konjunkturpaket die
wirtschaftliche krise wird schwer aber
nur kurz das ist die optimistische
botschaft der forscher von heute denn
deutschland sei gut gerüstet mit dem
bewährten kurzarbeitergeld aber auch mit
den neu geschaffenen schutzschirmen der
bundesregierung aber nur selten war eine
prognose wohl
so unsicher wie heute so nehmen die
forscher etwa an dass die beschränkungen
bereits ab dem 20
april schrittweise gelockert werden ihr
optimistisch in europa sind vor allem
die südländer wie italien und spanien
stark getroffen von den wirtschaftlichen
folgen der korona pandemie wie ihnen
geholfen werden kann darüber konnten
sich die euro-finanzminister letzte
nacht nicht einigen
streit gibt es vor allem darüber welche
auflagen die länder erfüllen müssen
denen geholfen wird
16 stunden hatten die finanzminister per
video-konferenz debattiert der deutsche
finanzminister schäuble sagte danach er
hoffe dass es noch vor ostern eine
einigung gebe eines ist in dieser krise
klar geworden die ausstattung der
kliniken ist essentiell
jedes zusätzliche intensivbetten leben
sagt der chef des robert koch instituts
allerdings war bislang nicht klar wie
viele intensivbetten hierzulande
überhaupt für immer mehr corona
patienten zur verfügung stehen ein neues
zentralregister gibt jetzt einen
überblick
an seinem stamm hier ist die virus krise
der kampf ums überleben wenn bei
komapatienten die lungen versagen
braucht es sofort künstliche beatmung
die stationen hier im krankenhaus in
mühldorf in bayern beispielsweise haben
18 intensivbetten mit beatmungsgeräten
alle werden gebraucht
wir hatten hier tatsächlich zeiten wo
wir die intensivstation und die
zusätzlichen
völlig ausgebucht haben ja wo hier 18
intensivpatienten ganz extrem wichtig in
der krise ist die übersicht deshalb
sollen jetzt alle krankenhäuser in
deutschland ihre zahlen an ein zentrales
register übermitteln das läuft langsam
an stand heute haben etwa 60 prozent der
kliniken meldung gemacht sie haben
insgesamt 16.000 intensivbetten das sind
ausschließlich die betten die
tatsächlich einsatzbereit sind gut 9000
sind belegt mehr als 6.800 frei deutlich
größer werden weil nämlich viele
kliniken noch nicht endgültig
eingeschrieben sind das heißt wärme
deutsch hörerzahl am wochenende hatten
wir beispielsweise 9500 frei
intensivbetten fast doppelt so viele wie
ganz italien italien mit vielen toten
und einem überlasteten gesundheitssystem
kein szenario dass deutschland akut ruhe
wir sind verhalten optimistisch dass das
szenario vor dem wir angst gehabt haben
und eigentlich immer noch angst haben
müssen in weite ferne gerückt ist und
wir im moment eine stabile situation
sehen genügend betten haben und wirklich
die patientenversorgung die schwer
erkrankt sind
das tun sie auf den intensivstationen
tag und nacht in mühldorf hat sich die
lage leicht entspannt mehrere
schwerkranke corona patienten konnten in
andere kliniken verlegt werden
ob die ausstattung tatsächlich reicht
das hängt wie eben gehört vom ausmaß der
ausbreitung ab schauen wir also auf die
zahlen in deutschland stand 18 uhr 30
laut johns hopkins universität sind mehr
als 109.000 infektionen bestätigt davon
sind 2096 menschen gestorben und mehr
als 36.000 genesen aktuell verlangsamt
sich die ausbreitung weiter anfang märz
hatte sich die zahl der erkrankten noch
alle zwei tage verdoppelt nun sind es
14,5 tage die verdopplung zeit ist eines
von mehreren kriterien dafür ob die
bundesregierung die beschränkungen
lockert überhaupt mag sich mancher
fragen sind diese beschränkungen der
regierung nicht etwas übertrieben
mehrere deutsche haben sich deshalb
beschwert ihre persönliche freiheit etwa
freunde oder verwandte zu treffen würde
zu sehr eingeschränkt stellvertretend
für alle wurde jetzt der eilantrag eines
byers vom bundesverfassungsgericht
abgewiesen
der schutz der gesundheit aller gehe
über den schutz persönlicher freiheiten
entschieden die richter
weltweit die meisten corona infektionen
gibt es mittlerweile in den usa und die
zahlen steigen weiter rasant
mehr als 400.000 menschen haben sich
infiziert allein 2000 starben innerhalb
von 24 stunden so viele wie nirgends
sonst
und offenbar trifft die pandemie
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen stärker
als andere afroamerikaner erkranken und
sterben an profit 19 sehr viel häufiger
als weiße immer tee lassen
es sind dramatische zahlen das corona
virus trifft mit besonderer härte vor
allem minderheiten in den usa
afroamerikaner und hispanics unter den
todesopfern in louisiana sind 70%
schwarzer obwohl sie nur ein drittel der
bevölkerung ausmachen in illinois 41
prozent der korona toten bei 15 prozent
anteil an der bevölkerung die verteilung
der krankheitsfälle erzählt eine
geschichte von ungleichheit dr black dog
in new york erlebt das jeden tag
david 19 ist der perfekte sturm für
schwarze und hispanics mit meist
niedrigem einkommen keinem zugang zu
tests viele arbeiten an der front als
unverzichtbare helfer oder im
dienstleistungsgewerbe sowie philip
thomas und wheldons beide starben beide
arbeiteten in einem supermarkt für ihre
krankenversicherung übergewicht und
vorerkrankungen tragen zu dem problem
bei schrecklich nannte donald trump die
entwicklung und versprach hilfe
gleichzeitig erhob er schwere vorwürfe
gegen die weltgesundheitsorganisation
sie hätte viel zu spät vor der pandemie
gewarnt
sie lagen falls sie hätten monate vorher
warnen können wir werden unsere
finanzhilfen seien die whu ein
ablenkungsmanöver denn die kürzung der
beihilfe steht seit monaten in trance
haushaltsentwurf und der geheimdienst
des pentagons hatte das weiße haus wohl
schon ende november vor einer zitat
katastrophalen epidemie gewarnt
derweil müssen sich immer mehr menschen
in den usa arbeitslos melden
besonders betroffen die niedriglohn jobs
also wieder schwarze und hispanics wegen
der korona krise war der wahlkampf in
den usa gerade etwas in den hintergrund
gerückt vor zwei stunden dann die
überraschende nachricht von den
demokraten
bernie sanders steigt aus der 78 jährige
zieht seine bewerbung um die
präsidentschaftskandidatur der
demokraten zurück der linke senator
hatte zuletzt bei mehreren vorwahlen
schwächer abgeschnitten als sein
parteiinterner rivale joe biden
damit wird wohl der ehemalige
vizepräsident im november gegen
präsident jump antreten
die us demokraten wollen auf einem
parteitag im august ihren kandidaten
küren mrt wissen in washington warum
zieht sich gar nicht sein dass
ausgerechnet jetzt zurück
also das hat senders vorhin in seinem
video statement sehr sehr klar gemacht
es geht ihm darum den wie er ihn nennt
gefährlichsten amerikanischen
präsidenten der jüngeren geschichte zu
besiegen und deshalb will er sich hinter
die nominierung von joe biden auf dem
parteitag im sommer stellen aber es
fehlte ein bisschen der glühende appell
an seine anhänger dass sie eben auch joe
biden unterstützen sollen im gegenteil
er will in den nächsten wochen bei den
vorwahlen weiterhin mit seinem namen auf
dem stimmzettel bleiben weiter
delegierten stimmen sammeln damit er
beim parteitag im sommer dann möglichst
viel gewicht hat um seine inhalte
durchzusetzen
donald trump hat vorhin getwittert dass
wahrscheinlich hier das establishment
der demokratischen partei centers
rausgedrängt habe ich glaube es geht um
was anderes
es geht wie joe biden immer sagt um die
seele der nation deshalb hat der
vizepräsident der ehemalige sich an die
anhänger von centers gewendet er sagt
ich sehe sie ich höre sie ich sehe die
dringlichkeit ihre anliegen und hat
ihnen gesagt gemeinsam wollen wir diese
nation nicht nur wieder aufbauen sondern
transformieren
also er will ganz offensichtlich die
anhänger von senders mitnehmen und ich
bin sicher dass sich sein dass dann auch
hinter die beiden stellen wird
dankeschön für diese schnelle
einschätzung aus washington martin ist
zurück zur corona krise was ist bedeutet
monatelang wegen des virus eingesperrt
zu sein das wissen die bewohner von buch
an der chinesischen millionenstadt in
der mitte dezember alles angefangen
hatte jetzt feiert man so etwas wie den
vorläufigen sieg über den unsichtbaren
feind
ab heute dürfen die bewohner wieder raus
aus der stadt
es ist ein triumph mit angezogener
handbremse
so groß die angst corona könnte wieder
außer kontrolle geraten
stefanie schöneborn und wohl voller
es ist der tag auf den ganzen hang
gewartet hat die menschen dürfen die
stadt verlassen
tausende machen sich auf den weg reisen
zu ihren familien oder zur arbeit
ich bin sehr glücklich endlich komme ich
nach hause ich war lang nicht mehr zu
hause
ich bin ganz aufgeregt gestern nacht
konnte ich überhaupt nicht schlafen
doch bei aller öffnungs euphorie bleibt
die angst von neuinfektionen und einer
rückkehr des virus die züge sind aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht voll und die
kontrollen sind weiterhin massiv die
chinesische regierung hat externe presse
tour organisiert um uns das hier zu
zeigen ein ganz wichtiges bild
verschiedener denn es soll belegen dass
man das virus besiegt hat viele kritiker
sagen es ist wahrscheinlich die richtige
strategie langsam die stadt zu öffnen
aber die gefahr besteht nun dass das
virus mitreißt auch am flughafen ist die
angst zu spüren
aus vorsicht geht kein flieger nach
peking egal wer reißt die menschen hier
tragen fast alle masken viele handschuhe
und schutzanzüge ich bin unsicher weil
während der reisen gibt es auch gefahren
ich weiß nicht was passieren kann ich
habe angst dass ich einem begegne der
keine symptome hat anstecken mit dem
tödlichen virus chinas kontrollen gehen
in alle richtungen nach fünf tagen dreh
in wo hahn geht es ins krankenhaus zum
testen für unser team
wenn wir anders machen und damit ganz
klar
sein können
nicht im 40 sonst bekommen wir kannten
wir stehen oben wenig mehr peking wollen
sondern die einfach in johann wieder
anfangen zu arbeiten
wir müssen auch alkohol anders machen
mit einer imposanten lichtershow wird
johann gefeiert als heldenstadt 76 tage
lang haben die menschen den lockdown
ihrer stadt mit dem virus gelebt und
überlebt doch normalität ist noch lange
nicht da eine ausführliche reportage aus
johann können sie heute abend in einem
auslandsjournal spezial sehen um 22 uhr
viele deutsche haben im moment tickets
bei sich zu hause liegen gekauft vor
corona für konzerte oder theater etwa
veranstaltungen die jetzt ausfallen oder
verschoben werden müssen
das sonst übliche prinzip geld zurück
würde aber etliche veranstalter
finanziell in die knie zwingen
deswegen hat die regierung entschieden
in den meisten fällen müssen sich die
kunden mit gutscheinen statt bargeld
zufrieden geben felix zimmermann in
frankfurt am main bringen seit mehr als
58 jahren die theatervorstellungen der
komödie die zuschauer zum lachen
durch die korona krise brechen dem
theaterdirektor claus helmer nicht nur
die einnahmen weg sondern kunden und
abonnenten verlangen auch geld zurück
wenn alle abonnenten das sieht so
zweieinhalbtausend dann durch zwei
produktionen es geht zurück haben wollen
dann geht es in die zehntausende
insgesamt geht es um viele millionen die
sport konzert und andere freizeit
veranstalter wegen ausgefallener
veranstaltung nun eigentlich
zurückzahlen müssten
doch die regierung brachte heute ein
neues gesetz auf den weg statt geld
sollen die kunden nur noch ein gutschein
erhalten
ziel die rettung der unternehmen denn
viele von denen ständen jetzt vor dem
wirtschaftlichen aus wenn alle
verbraucher ihren anspruch auf
rückerstattung der ticketkosten geltend
machen würden die verbraucherzentrale
kritisierte regelung kunden würden damit
gezwungen unternehmen geld zu leihen bei
veranstaltungen konzerten usw gibt es
keinerlei insolvenz absicherung das
heißt
die gutscheine werden später vielleicht
nicht mal mehr das papier wert sein auf
das sie gedruckt werden
eintrittskarten sind erst der anfang die
regierung will die gutscheinlösung auch
für pauschalreisen und flugtickets
umsetzen
doch hier steht nach europarecht im weg
aktuell wird auf eu ebene verhandelt dem
direkt deutsche komödie wird die
gutschein regelung nur wenig helfen
sondern nur die baldige wiedereröffnung
und das lachen verlängertes leben also
ich hoffe dass wir bald so weit sind
dass wir den leuten das leben verlängern
können gutscheine für kultur und sport
veranstalter und wer rettet den
einzelhandel dazu gleich ein zdf spezial
um 19 uhr 25 direkt nach uns und
jederzeit informieren können sie sich
auch online mit unserer zdf heute app
wie corona krise trifft uns alle aber
wie so oft die ärmsten am heftigsten
mehr auf der straße lebt der kann sich
schlecht dauernd die hände waschen
außerdem brechen obdachlosen im moment
fast alle versorgungslücken beck bobby
cherry an berichtet seit mehr als 20
jahren kümmert sich der sozialmediziner
gerhard trabert um die betreuung von
obdachlosen in und um mainz während der
korona pandemie hört er damit nicht auf
denn für obdachlose sei die gefahr durch
das neue virus besonders groß viele sind
chronisch krank sind also eine
risikogruppe
sie haben kein zuhause sie können sich
nicht einfach zurückziehen deshalb sind
sie besonders gefährdet
schätzungen zufolge haben rund 678.000
menschen in deutschland keinen festen
wohnsitz
41.000 von ihnen leben ohne irgendeine
unterkunft auf der straße durch die
korona pandemie sind viele hilfsangebote
weggebrochen notunterkünfte sind
geschlossen ebenso essensausgaben und
kleiderkammern spenden fallen weg
obdachlose die durch das corona virus
besonders gefährdet sind dürfen in mainz
jetzt im business hotel wohnen andere
gäste gibt es ja gerade ohnehin nicht
einer der neuen bewohner ist klaus
perlich 78 jahre alt
eine zusätzliche sicherheit und ich
hoffe dass die diese solche muss ich um
bei einer sagen bald ein ende
die kosten tragen die stadt mainz das
land rheinland pfalz und das hotel
mindestens bis zum 20 april können 30
obdachlose hier geschützt wohnen die
eu-kommission gegen polen schon länger
dauert dieser streit brüssel sind die
polnischen justizreformen ein dorn im
auge denn den national- konservative
regierung würde damit die unabhängigkeit
der richter im land aushebeln so der
vorwurf
der europäische gerichtshof sieht das
genauso und bringt jetzt die regierung
in warschau mit einem entsprechenden
beschluss erheblich unter druck natalie
steger berichtet igor toya ist richter
am warschauer bezirksgericht und einer
der fälle die vor der neuen
disziplinarkammer gelandet sind
die kammer ist ein schlüsselelement der
justizreform sie kann jeden richter in
polen entlassen
nun hat der ogh polen aufgefordert die
arbeit der disziplinarkammer
unverzüglich auszusetzen
die heutige entscheidung ist die krönung
des kampfes der bürger der fünf jahre
dauerte ein kampf um die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in unserem land zu
layer hatte medienvertreter im
gerichtssaal zugelassen als ihr ein
urteil verkündete dass der national
konservativen regierungspartei nicht
gefiel
in der disziplinarkammer sitzen vor
allem juristen aus dem umfeld der
regierung ihre besetzung ist umstritten
die zuständigkeit der disziplinarkammer
für das
im verfahren gegen richter kann somit zu
einem schweren und nicht wieder
gutzumachenden schaden für die unions
rechtsordnung und den gemeinsamen
grundwerte der rechtsstaatlichkeit
führen
polens ministerpräsident meldete zweifel
an ob der ogh überhaupt zuständig ist
eine justizreform gehört allein zur
kompetenz der mitgliedstaaten noch
könnte sich die arbeit der
disziplinarkammer erledigt haben denn
polens regierung hat sich bislang
jedenfalls an verfügungen und urteile
des bgh gehalten
es ist eine schwere schlappe für die pis
beim umbau der justiz in polen
der klimawandel setzt dem deutschen wald
zu hitze und dürre der letzten jahre
haben sichtbare spuren hinterlassen
noch nie ist der anteil der bäume mit
gesunden kronen so gering gewesen wie im
vergangenen jahr
das zeigt der waldzustandsbericht der
bundesregierung durch die milden winter
wurden zudem weniger schädlinge sterben
die autoren des berichts fordern einen
konsequenten klimaschutz und eine
nachhaltige forstwirtschaft abstand
halten das ist in diesen zeiten oberstes
gebot einer aber kam vergangene nacht
für seine verhältnisse ungewöhnlich nahe
der mond als sogenannte super vollmond
strahlte er für unser bloßes auge
besonders groß und hell am horizont so
zog er seine bahn einmal um die ganze
welt über moskau und in creme
[Musik]
die notre dame in paris
und new york zu sehen gibt es das
spektakel immer dann wenn der mond auf
seiner elliptischen umlaufbahn unserer
erde besonders nahe kommt das nächste
mal leider erst im mai 2021
dafür gibt es jetzt direkt die
lottozahlen vielleicht machen wir auch
jemanden glücklich
sie lauten 5 18 22 25 31 44 und die
superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157 und noch zum wetter
es wird kühler im norden und sehr waren
im süden die details hat gleich ist
intelli claus kleber freut sich auf sie
im heute journal um 10 und wir freuen
uns über ihr interesse und ihren
zuspruch haben sie einen guten abend bis
morgens und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter aus dem norden
erreicht uns eine kaltfront aber die
sorgt gerade mal für einige wolken und
wenige tropfen im osten deutschlands
schauen wir in die nacht da gibt es im
norden wieder wenige wolken ansonsten
aber funkeln die sterne und die
temperaturen sinken am alpenrand bis auf
2 grad am niederrhein auf 11 grad
morgen kommen die wolken der kaltfront
etwa bis zur mitte voran ein paar
tropfen gibt es richtung erzgebirge viel
wird es nicht sein auf der rückseite der
kaltfront wird wieder freundlicher und
richtig sonnig im südwesten deutschlands
und dort erwartet uns 25 grad also ein
sommertag definitionsgemäß ganz im
norden ist es kühler bei 11 bis 13 grad
sommertag ist auch das stichwort für die
nächsten tage am karfreitag zb bis 25
grad mehr wolken im norden viel
sonnenschein im süden
ja und am karsamstag sieht es ähnlich
aus bis 26 grad warm und ostersonntag
gibt es im nordwesten dann neue wolken
mit regen damit wünsche ich ihnen einen
schönen abend